let's say that we have a polynomial p of
x
and we can factor it and we can put it
in the form
x minus 1 times x plus 2
times x minus 3 times x plus 4
and what we are concerned with are the
zeros of this polynomial and you might
say what is a zero of a polynomial well
those are the x values that are going to
make the polynomial equal to zero so
another way to think about it is for
what x values is p of x going to be
equal to zero or another way you can
think about it is for what x values is
this expression going to be equal to
zero so for what x values is x minus one
times x plus two times x minus three
times x plus four
going to be equal to zero
i encourage you to pause this video
think about that a little bit before we
work through it together
well the key realization here is if you
have the product of a bunch of
expressions if any one of them is equal
to zero it doesn't matter what the
others are because zero times anything
else is going to be equal to zero so the
fancy term for that is the zero product
property but all it says is hey if you
can find an x value that makes any one
of these expressions equal to zero well
that's going to make the entire
expression going to be it's going to
make the entire expression equal to zero
so the zeros of this polynomial are
going to be the x values that could make
x minus one equal to zero
so x minus one equals zero we know what
x value would would make that happen if
x is equal to 1 if you add 1 to both
sides here x equals 1. so x equals 1 is
a 0 of this polynomial another way to
say that is p of 1 when x equals 1 that
whole polynomial is going to be equal to
0. how do i know that well if i put a 1
in right over here
this
expression right here x minus 1 that is
going to be equal to 0. so you have 0
times a bunch of other stuff which is
going to be equal to 0.
and so by the same idea we can figure
out what the other zeros are
what would make
this part equal to zero what x value
would make x plus two equal to zero
well x equals negative two
x equals negative 2 would make x plus 2
equals 0. so x equals negative 2 is
another 0 of this polynomial and we
could keep going
what would make x minus 3 equal to 0
well if x is equal to three that would
make x minus three equal to zero and
that would then make the entire
expression equal to zero and then last
but not least what would make x plus
four equal to zero
well if x is equal to negative four and
just like that we have found four zeros
for this polynomial when x equals one
the polynomial is equal to zero when x
equals negative two the polynomial is
equal to zero when x equals three the
polynomial is equal to zero and when x
equals negative four the polynomial is
equal to zero
and one of the interesting things about
the zeros of a polynomial you could
actually use that to start to sketch out
what the graph might look like
so for example we know that this
polynomial is going to take on the value
zero at these zeros
so let me just draw a rough sketch right
over here so this is my x-axis that's my
y-axis
so it's my y-axis and so let's see at x
equals one so let me just do it this way
so we have one
two
three
and four and then you have negative one
negative two
negative three and then last but not
least negative four
we know that this polynomial p of x is
going to be equal to zero at x equals
one so it's going to intersect the
x-axis right there it's going to be
equal to
zero at x equals negative two so right
over there at x equals 3 right over
there and x equals negative 4.
now we don't know exactly what the graph
looks like just based on this we could
try out some values on either side to
figure out hey is it above the x-axis or
below the x-axis for x-values less than
negative 4 and we can try things out
like that but we know it intersects the
x-axis at these points so it might look
something like
this this is a very rough sketch it
might look something like this
we don't know without doing a little bit
more work
but ahead of time i took a look at what
this looks like i went on to desmos and
i graphed it and you can see it looks
exactly as what we would expect the
graph of this polynomial intersects the
x-axis at x equals negative 4. actually
let me color-code it x equals negative 4
and that is that 0 right over there
x equals negative 2
that's this 0 right there
x equals 1
right over there
and then x equals 3
right over there
in future videos we will study this in
even more depth